[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here happy new year
I'm back I'm feeling fitter healthier
and more alive from the inside out last
year I have to admit that I've given in
to stress and also emotional eating and
I just needed some time off this year I
told myself I'm back on track
I want to start looking up to my
well-being again and no more crazy
emotional eating so I started using the
lifestyle app to help me track my meals
and also activity levels this app makes
being healthy really easy so whether
your goal is to lose weight to put on
weight or to maintain your current
weight it has all the right information
to guide you through your progress from
logging your daily food intake and
exercises to step-by-step recipes and
even meal plans cater to your diet so if
you want a really easy and fun way to
track your progress throughout this year
I would encourage you to download this
app try it out by clicking on the link
in my description box so one of my
favorite features on this app is called
the live skull test basically you answer
a series of 40 questions about your food
habits and also activity levels be
honest with yourself at the end of the
test you receive a tailored feedback on
ways that you can improve so according
to my test I know that I need to
increase my food intake especially
berries and to start introducing legumes
and lots of beans into my diet and also
go easy on the streets no more crazy -
munching Joanna so I've also been going
through all the recipes on this app and
recreated them according to my
preference it's really simple just
happen what you want to eat and you will
see a long list of healthy recipes I
selected the whole and healthy clear
eating plan and I'm going to share with
you my vegan it clean meal plan inspired
by these recipes so my focus is to
really get more fruits of vegetables and
also plant-based protein into my diet so
for breakfast I made the blueberry chia
pudding in a bowl or jar combine two
tablespoons of chia seeds with quarter
cup of fresh or frozen blueberries have
a cup of milk and half a teaspoon of
vanilla
all you have to do is mix it up cover
and let it set overnight in the fridge
the next morning top it up with one
small sliced banana and two tablespoons
of pumpkin seeds I like to keep my
breakfast simple and I tend to make a
three or four bowls ahead
so this breakfast helps with my
digestion and I'm also getting more
berries and also fruits into my diet so
let me just add that in two fruits
serving checked s for lunch I wanted a
really simple Asian rice recipe which I
can prep ahead and bring it up with me
so I recreated a depend fried Indian
wild rice what you'll need are one cup
of cooked rice I used a mixture of brown
and white rice about one cup of sliced
zucchinis half a cup of broccoli cut
into small florets half a cup of carrots
sliced 2 spring onions sliced 1/2 a
tablespoon of oil about 3 tablespoons of
unsalted cashew nuts 2 tablespoons of
raisins 1 and 1/2 teaspoon of curry
powder and about half a cup of vegetable
stock so in a pot of boiling salted
water blanch the broccoli and carrots
for about 2 minutes drain and set aside
hits oil over medium-high heat stir in
the cashew nuts raisins and all the
vegetables saute for about 3 minutes and
stir in the spring onions curry powder
and cook for a couple more minutes then
pour in the vegetable stock and allowed
all the ingredients to simmer until the
vegetables are tender finally mix in the
rice remove from heat and serve so I'm
just going to take a quick picture of my
lunch and log it into the app this one's
serving a fried rice add to 2 of my
vegetable servings
it is also packed with complex carbs to
keep me full and satisfied
no more mindless mid-afternoon snacking
so be sure to try this recipe and take
it up with you to school or work as for
dinner I wanted a simple one pot dish
and to start introducing beans and
legumes into my diet so I tried the
warming rut
with beings what you need are one large
onion 2 garlic cloves 2 medium zucchinis
one red bell pepper and one eggplant all
roughly chopped 1 tbsp of olive oil
about 800 gram or 2 cans of crushed
tomatoes 1 can of white beans rinsed and
drained 1 tablespoon of balsamic vinegar
1/2 a teaspoon of ground cumin 1
teaspoon of dried mixed herbs and salt
and pepper to taste
heat olive oil over medium-high heat
lightly stir fry the onion and garlic
for about 2 minutes stir in the eggplant
zucchini and bell pepper cook for
another 5 minutes until vegetables start
to brown stir in the tomatoes beans for
Samak vinegar cumin dried herbs and salt
and pepper cover and cook for another 30
minutes and to vegetables are tender
don't forget to stir occasionally and
serve warm so I would recommend you to
make this dish in bulk freeze it up and
just reheat when you want to eat it for
dinner or lunch so let me just add that
into my dinner and I served it with two
slices of toasts and also tomato salsa
there you have it I've met my vegetable
goal and as for my snacks I had a bottle
of fruit smoothie when I was out a
protein shake after my workout and also
a handful of trail mix prior to my
workouts so basically at the end of the
day I get to track all my meals my
exercises have I drank enough water and
did I achieve my vegetable and also
fruit
goals which I did yay so guys I would
encourage you to download the lifestyle
app for free by clicking on the link in
my description box below I trust that
this app will help guide you through
your fitness journey and also help you
achieve your fitness goals what are your
fitness goals for 2017 do let me know in
the comments below
if you enjoy this video if you love the
recipes be sure to give it a thumbs up
share this meal time with your friends
and subscribe to my youtube channel for
more fun fit and a lot more exciting
this year guys I wish you all the love
joy and abundance for 2017 all the best
[Music]
you
[Music]